bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france 17 réunions
organisées depuis le lancement officiel
13 mai dernier elle des négociations
entre le liban et le fmi c'est beaucoup
c'est pas tellement le vote aux réunions
qui compte c'est le contenu que tim est
dans ces réunions les différentes
parties prenantes parce que l'attitude à
la fois de l'union européenne et du
fonds monétaire international ne fait
que reproduire des schémas classiques et
lâche dont on connaît déjà le résultat
c'est à dire une aggravation de la
situation sociale pour les populations
et une sortie de crise qui n'aura pas
lieu bien nos confrères l'union
européenne par exemple je veux pas lui
mettre tout sur le dos n'est pas le
responsable de tout ce qui se passe au
liban mais il faut quand même rappeler
l'accord de libre échange conclu en 2006
entre le liban et l'union européenne qui
a abouti à un affaiblissement
considérable de l'économie libanaise
parce que on a imposé avec cet accord
l'ouverture totale des frontières la
suppression des protections douanières
et on a mis cette petite économie des
neiges en concurrence directe avec les
géants européens à un français allemands
britanniques
le résultat a été celui auquel il
fallait s'attendre c'est un écroulement
des exportations libanaises
le liban s'est trouvé dans une situation
aujourd'hui de déficit de sa balance des
paiements le déficit commercial pour
résumer disons avec des milliards de
déficit son marché intérieur a été
envahie par les produits étrangers
notamment européens champ d'activité
industrielle a été étouffé par l'enjeu
on le rappelle en jeu dans ces
négociations le fameux programme
d'ajustement structurel
pour quelle raison parce que les
contreparties demandées par le fmi ne
peuvent-elles ne peuvent pas être
fournies par le liban il y a évidemment
des raisons académiques c'est peut-être
pas le moment d'en parler ici mais il y
a des raisons historiques empirique
toute l'expérience des plans
d'ajustement structurel que ce soit en
afrique ou que ce soit plus récemment et
plus près de nous en grèce ont démontré
que ça ne donnait aucun résultat social
attention ces plans d'ajustement
structurel donne des résultats pour les
propriétaires de capitaux 1
pour ceux qui n'ont que leur force de
travail à vendre pas pour la population
et la situation est vraiment daterait de
similaire entre la grèce et le liban on
a vu que la troïka en grèce c'est à dire
le fmi l'union européenne la commission
européenne la banque centrale européenne
avait mise en place que l'on appelle des
plans d'ajustement structurel autrement
dit toujours les mêmes recettes il
suffirait d'ailleurs de mettre un enfant
de dix ans à la tête du fmi
pour répliquer indéfiniment les mêmes
recettes il son austérité pour la
population qui sont réduction de la
dette publique précisément par
l'austérité mais ce n'est pas du tout ce
qu'il faut faire et l'expérience grec
devrait quand même de montrer un certain
nombre de gens qu'il ne faut pas
reproduire ce genre de politique alors
que votre faudrait-il faire sur le plan
extérieur au liban il faut évidemment
que les créanciers acceptent une
annulation à 10 ans nous ce qu'on
appelle pudiquement une restructuration
de la dette de la dette publique du
liban bien entendu mais sans
contrepartie d'austérité parce que dans
la situation explosive dans laquelle se
trouve ce pays un surcroît d'austérité
de ces ajouter de l'huile sur le feu
ajoutons qu'au même qu' il y à un
million et demi de réfugiés série
irakiens palestiniens personne n'a aidé
le liban
c'est comme la grèce à l'époque de
personnes alors que bonn banc dans cette
situation deux jouent un rôle du point
de vue de l'intérêt humain tout à fait
important on le laisse tomber et donc de
l'austérité supplémentaires sur cette
situation
ce serait un véritable crime merci pour
votre analyse jacques nikonoff je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste
président du parti m